thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello
hello hello hello
you guys like the new emotes
they're pretty cute
oh the new couch is here in US
Joy is currently not laying on it
because she wants to look out the window
that's okay
she's laying on it all morning so I know
she likes it
but how is everybody's Thursday going so
far hope it's going well
[Music]
hopefully we have a better stream today
than we did yesterday
yesterday was rough in a few areas
it happens
[Music]
Vigor check 99 my guy we are fully maxed
out leveled
what does member mean
um you support the channel it's uh you
get a badge next to your name you get uh
you can use emotes your name will be
green stuff like that it's like being a
sub on Twitch if you know what that is
I'm working from home and on a laptop
let's go Trey
we have more got to Great Rune we do
since when is the stream waiting
background so cool
I don't know man
all right
yes only bigger
[Music]
you guys ready for the couch
look at this bro
[Music]
there it is
that is a very nice big comfy couch
enjoys laying right here
it is a big couch
another thing I should add is that the
couch was completely free
so
I gotta take the couch man
now guys uh before you guys start asking
questions about this
I am no longer sponsored by gamerseps
but you should check them out because I
actually believe in what they do
uh they send me cups Faker cups with
their logo
and stuff like this
I have three of these
if you're interested in cups like this I
am not sponsored by these people
but I used to be
and they sell like healthy alternatives
to uh
pre-workout
I put my morning Shake in here
so before everyone starts asking like
Jake what the heck is that cup
now you know okay
[Music]
you want the light in the background to
be red but
boom
right as hell boys
I've got a couple new lights coming
um so it'll be brighter in a few few
days and I'll have one right here this
will be a red or
LED stick here and an LED stick back
there
where can we buy it gamersups.com
I guess I'll give them a free shout out
go for it
[Music]
stop Yusuf
let us continue
yesterday we were fighting Godfrey and
we got so frustrated with the chat
that I had to stop
God damn bro
how do you pronounce that
um the statue in moguin's Palace chap
isn't it you will
is that how you say it
you'll
what does a 99 Vigor even look like
goes that far across the screen
how is this in-game how is it not in
game okay I'm not gonna I'm not already
gonna get frustrated
it's [ __ ] Godfrey
already frustrated
I don't know how to pronounce it
I miss doggo of death you did you can go
watch the um
the VOD from yesterday
if you wish
you call it old that's a much easier way
to say it
old so Ood
the capital is mid game you're literally
stupid I'm sorry
you're stupid
or you literally haven't gotten this far
e pronounce it the nice way how does he
pronounce it
yep time that guy out for being stupid
okay so I said in the Discord yeah I got
a new couch so I said in the Discord
that I found a way
to
um
to negate
these stupid people in the chat because
they're they have been coming out like
wildfire the last week or so right
I don't know what's going on I don't
know what happened but ever since I hit
a hundred thousand Subs we have stupid
people in the chat like [ __ ] crazy
and it's annoying as hell
so what I did is I'm instead of yelling
at them like I just did so I'm already
breaking what I want to do here
I think we start calling them NPCs
and we start using this emote
whenever they come out of the woodwork
to be stupid
NPC
you're
stupid not stupid no NPC
we have a back seat emote as well
like anyone who says that this is an
in-game you're an NPC and You're dumb
okay
and that's all
I pet my dog constantly Drew
we also have a frost pots emote because
that's become a [ __ ] meme in this
chat too
it really has
yeah I don't think this is gonna go well
but I'm gonna fight him
let's just kick it off baby
[Music]
no runes
foreign
God I wish I did more damage
[Music]
foreign
y'all see it right
[Music]
oh come on
foreign
hurry up and he told me to Traverse the
fog while I'm fighting him that's an NPC
foreign
no
big damage
maybe I just ignore the people being
stupid in chat
and you guys call them NPCs I'm just
gonna have to rely on you guys I
literally can't call them out I can't do
it or people get confused they get I
don't know
I'll stop
you guys call him out free
foreign
that sucks
[Music]
thank you
what
gotta be real patient chat with four Lou
wait for the opportunities
[Music]
yep
that's kind of cringe
we're chilling
gotta be real patient
probably could have attacked another
time there
nice
not not as nice
that could have been bad
foreign
Creed
you tried to end my day right there
damn
[Music]
what
I don't know how to hit me I literally
don't
that's okay
foreign
baby
no [ __ ] he delayed his thing
you delay that
[Music]
[Music]
no
that was our first attempt by the way
that would have been insane
I've never seen him delay that [ __ ]
attack before man
I've never seen him delay that attack
before
it felt like a delay anyway maybe it
wasn't
we're dodging like a [ __ ] though
just in the second phase there's no
opportunities to do this
[Music]
unless he does the big Roar
and he does the step right
it's kind of as good as we can get Stan
honestly
it's kind of as good as we can get
I'm going to use this for stage one
because we literally can't do it stage
two
for the most part
okay what is this combo
okay that was like seven attacks in a
row by the way
he caught me tripping
okay he's not doing anything I want him
to do right here
come on
oh the stamp I think the stamina is the
hardest thing about this build to be
honest
you have to manage it so perfectly
[Music]
thank you
I should do the big attacks there
well now I can get one
that'll be okay I just don't have the
stamina to do two
he threw his ax
hmm
give me a second here there we go
there you go Chad you're what you're
learning
thank you
it's a ride card no [ __ ] man okay
no [ __ ] bro
oh no
god what the [ __ ] was that
foreign
the leg sweep is such a cool animation I
don't know how the first one hit me
there
[Music]
okay
not as good as the first attempt
but we are out here
[Music]
[Music]
damn it I wanted to be close
well I still can
all right that that's good I guess
[Music]
it's gonna be tough chat
[Music]
I'm going for one
that was fine
that sucks
that's okay
[Music]
he baited me he [ __ ]
right
see usually he slams into the ground
there and then he'll just like kind of
slowly get his hands out of the ground
and that time he was just like
he baited me that was a bad attempt
we got hit by a bunch of [ __ ] that we
didn't need
I'm doing so well though but I
definitely got debated there I'm gonna
do the thing that some NPC told me to do
yesterday which is this
if only we had one more
we don't use any FP at all
so
like not even this attack uses FP
does this
it for no reason that's so dumb
okay
uh I'm I'm good on that Dina it does
sound kind of fun though
[Music]
I thought he'd throw his ax in there
like he always does
huh
that's what I mean I get hit by stupid
[ __ ]
I don't know why Chad but this is the
attempt this is the one
confidence is really high
okay maybe not
Roar nope
big attack into another one
I have stamina nice
nice really good stamina management
there
really good
oh yeah
there we go
I guess I didn't have stamina
foreign
you're not wrong biggie
this will not be the one this will be
the one that will Thruster you enough to
win the next one
got it Victor
I think this is one of the best fights
in the game
do you guys agree
this is such a fun fight
[Music]
ow
did he delay that time
until
I don't think so
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
Roar
that's chill
[Music]
one
[Music]
[ __ ]
I did it again
[Music]
[Music]
you're too greedy
I should have healed their chat
we got lucky he wanted to jump
that was kind of weird
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I don't even know how I'm getting hit
I'm not kidding I don't know
I felt like I dodged and I didn't
grab more than ever
the [ __ ] kick heal
that was really smart
[Music]
did he [ __ ] bait me
I dude I swear to God all these
challenges we do
we have so many examples of when a boss
is low Health all of the rules of the
fight are completely thrown out the
window
like all the animations that he goes
through to do certain things
nope
they all go out the window
the animations stop he gets faster all
of a sudden he delays weird attacks
it is what it is
okay that's it's not our favorite start
[Music]
foreign
I can get a hit in there that's good to
know
I'm going for two [ __ ] it
[Music]
because I knew he was going to do that
[ __ ] it
that was stupid
we got the buff going why not baby
oh that combo is extremely rare
stage two stage two okay
I wasn't even close
to being correct on when he will
transition excellent
okay
[Music]
early jump
we do more damage not doing the crit
the big swings are what we do the most
damage with
[Music]
very rare in this fight
okay
phase two is just [ __ ] insane
hi Finn
that was just unlucky
unlucky man
I feel like he's delaying the grabs more
than I've ever seen
all right confidence level very high
foreign
good stamina back don't need to hit him
[Music]
such a rare attack for him to do there
okay it's fine we'll get them on the way
down
let's go for a couple of these
okay
might as well
I swear
sometimes the attack hits me and
sometimes it just doesn't
what would you consider Vigor is
doesn't it uh tell you like a lore
reason
could be wrong on that
[Music]
does he have three different grabs chat
that's like the third different
animation I've seen
huh
right
he literally didn't [ __ ] stop wow wow
holy [ __ ]
that was just non-stop
combo what he he will just decide
how many attacks he wants to do
man bro when you can't do enough damage
it's hard
it's hard man
the Wombo Combo
like the stream for a guaranteed win
chat
I agree Crow
everybody like The Scream
what's up Aaron
yup let's see how much help we have
foreign
seven hundred and sixteen
the couch is extremely comfy I was
laying on it all last night
new job poggers
I didn't use my physic did I uh-oh
that could be a problem
foreign
way less damage
I literally had no stamina at all
okay good opportunity here
I think we need to change our second
half of our physics
[Music]
I forget I can't jump into him there
unfortunately
we'll do them on the down
dirty
doing them dirty
might as well get the big hit
it'd be cool to have a Talisman
orientation that powers up bare hands
fighting is bare hands fighting possible
like fists only
I got phase one down Chad it's it's
horrorlu that's an issue
do y'all see my character role and it
just didn't matter
I guess I rolled it the wrong time
I'm like mid-roll and it still hits me I
don't get it
has anyone done fists only
thank you
man bro
I have like no physics I feel like we
should do the stamina
pick only and roll damage only
staff Bonk only
that's crazy
let's go
have a good day at work Carla
no great room this time by the way
I hate that combo
what up killer
man
not good fam
that's good though
he's definitely Gonna Roar here right
yeah yeah we'll get him on the downswing
I would love a Boss Rush mode that would
be so much fun
foreign
easiest W of their career
they did it for Securo
I don't know what that sound was
foreign
yeah I did that
I don't know
I don't get it
oh my
God I'll take it what the [ __ ]
Dodge in you [ __ ]
thank you
now drips
play the game
[Music]
man that is brutal
that combo he does is brutal
see it's a bait
yep it's that one right there
gotta be over
[Music]
one swing
there's like almost no attempts to like
hit him other than a light attack
[Music]
there's like no opportunities
[Music]
the latest stop
should have healed
[Music]
dude have y'all ever seen him delay
these attacks this much I swear they're
delayed or it's something in my head
do they look delayed to you as well
they're insane like he's just like
they look delayed but I I could be wrong
I don't know
they're normal man
that's crazy
a lot of chats saying it's delayed why'd
you say it's normal
yeah we've we've mastered first phase we
are really struggling with second phase
okay y'all are saying different things
so I don't really know who to believe
Roar
okay
foreign
[Music]
foreign
nice Erin
Suraj
[Music]
I wish this was an opportunity to hit
him but it is not
unfortunately
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
because we've seen it all a bunch of
times
I think that's pretty obvious
I want to get to the fight
I'm cool with getting knocked back
doesn't do any damage
I thought that was the bait
I don't get it he did like four [ __ ]
steps like I I if this was an NBA game
he'd be traveling
wait he did one step there
was our best time to hit him when we
couldn't
that sucks dick
I guess I ran to the side
come on you just
you just hit this
I thought he just wouldn't that time man
like that
[Music]
what
what I swear to God man this [ __ ]
doesn't make any sense
anyone in Chad who say any doesn't delay
you're literally just wrong
[Music]
foreign
excellent
oh this is hard man
yeah he definitely delays in really
awkward times
yes Alpha by a lot
since we only have 10 strength doing a
crit doesn't do anything
it doesn't even do like when you stab
him initially it like sometimes doesn't
even do damage like none zero
we've also learned
okay NPC in the chat NPC
I think you all see it
we've also learned that even if you have
99 vigor
the end game will still two shot you
no matter what
it's pointless to have this much bigger
chat
pointless
foreign
because I can't level stamina
I can barely have this armor on
I wouldn't really call that advice drips
I'd just call that completely off topic
I don't know what a plus seven spear
from patches would do for us right now
I'm calling them an NPC
foreign
I didn't manage my stamina properly
Dylan how would a standard broadsword
help us right now
out of curiosity
foreign
how do I dodge that attack
[Music]
I thought dodging in would be it and
it's just not
[Music]
foreign
see that time I dodged it
[Music]
no heal I pressed the button it didn't
do anything
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
maybe I should preface this
ask this real quick to people giving
suggestions in the chat which is okay
um if you're new here
do you guys think this is my first time
playing the game
just out of curiosity
[Music]
it's such a delayed slam
foreign
I crouched I couldn't tell I was
crouched man
should have healed there
[Music]
foreign
I really wish he jumped
[Music]
man I can't believe I can't roll there
foreign I don't know what to tell you I
did
but I guess I didn't in time
it sucks
chill
I got baited for the 50th time today
come on
Battle of Biggers
[Music]
foreign
close one bro
oh man
nice
very nice
sorry bro no don't be sorry I'm gonna
start whenever I don't recognize a name
in chat I'm gonna start being nicer
because maybe you just don't know how I
work and that's pretty obvious
but I I that was a genuinely curious
question
do you guys think this is my first time
playing to anyone who's new here
I've beaten this game close to a hundred
times man
what did this guy say
what Trey why are you timing out people
that said smooth dodges
what the heck
yeah clearly first time no I like
genuinely curious
because if somebody's in the chat going
like
and I'm being genuine right now
if someone in the chat is literally
where I'm at this point in the game and
they're saying you can get a plus seven
weapon from patches
that must mean you don't really know
that much about the game
that has to mean that and if that's true
that's okay
I might poke a little fun at you
a little bit
that's okay
um
dude Gideon and Godfrey have been
insanely hard
yeah the spear is good against Reichard
yeah like stuff like that dude like they
could be a kid they could be completely
new to Elden ring and they're just
trying to talk and chat like that's
totally fine I really need to start
thinking that way like maybe some people
are just like they don't have as many
hours in the game as as we do
and that's fine
so I'm gonna start thinking that way bro
I'm gonna start thinking that way
yeah I saw that on Twitch Landing that's
crazy
that's crazy bro
okay let's go get
um
the secret medallions
why magic why nothing else no armor
equals less resistance to fire
I mean that would make sense right where
am I going
how am I lost right now
it's over here
gotta lay the ground rules yeah dude
like
yeah I bet a lot of new folks to the
channel haven't seen the rampant
trolling and backseat gaming probably so
whenever I see an I'm going to be I'm
gonna try and be really good uh to
people with new names
that I haven't seen before
I gotta stop getting baited
just like how I'm getting baited by
Godfrey I gotta stop getting baited by
people in the chat I just have to get
better at that
I'm a God at the lore but I've never
played the game I that's definitely fun
oh yeah if I if you're a regular then
you guys know how I work I don't like to
I mean just to put it out there
because maybe some of you don't know
this
besides the many examples
of me doing this stuff whenever I enter
a fight I don't like to change up how I
entered the fight to just
make it easier I like to beat my head
against a wall until I beat it with what
I entered in with
I know apparently a lot of people don't
like that
and I wish I could fight mikola
does this run have a specific gimmick no
the turtle shell helps with stamina
Regen
and the spear does not require any
attributes to use so it's fully upgraded
and that's why we're using it
grim
all right press one in chat if we need a
Gideon emote that says we know
underneath his face
that's a great idea
we know
just like it'll be his helmet and then
underneath it it'll just say we know
that's so good
that's so good bro
uh-oh I'm in trouble
[Music]
he's so good all right I'll work on that
as soon as I can
we got our next emote
and then please
I love democracy
uh I play Souls games the same way I get
mad when my friends tell me take a break
or change the strategy I can't do that
dude whenever someone's like dude take a
break change it up I literally I get
more motivated to just not do what they
said
which I think is toxic like it's a toxic
trait of mine but it is a trait of mine
and that simply is what it is
you know what I mean that that just is
what it is man
we're getting the secret medallions and
then we're gonna go fight Moog and then
we're gonna go fight uh
we're gonna try Melania chat I
I don't know I might set some ground
rules for Melania just because I think
she's awful
but it might not be as bad
with a lot of Health
Maybe
I don't know
are you a bad boy what do you think
I'd probably just screamed no all right
I don't see this as toxic apparently a
lot of people do
you guys know that people were joining
the Discord from yesterday's stream and
literally telling me to
uh do bad things
to myself
uh when they got banned
is join the Discord and sent me this
like long-winded message of how they
hate my moderators and I should just you
know
I'm like all right
you're weird
yeah we have a Discord
to join it
what do you mean no Discord we have a
main Discord it's like over a thousand
people in it
we deleted the members only Discord and
then made members only channels in the
main Discord
oh I don't know the exact number Dakota
you could probably look that up
I don't agree with that guy
but didn't I get timed out earlier
all I said was this is not in game
what would you consider in-game then
besides Godfrey at and then you have
access to radagon and the eldenbeast
how much bigger a lot
like 2700
I was messing uh
I mean if you're gonna mess around we
gotta know who you are first you know
what I mean
you were joking it's a bad joke then
like I'm sorry
press one and chat if that's just not
funny
you gotta be funny to create you know to
have a joke
you know you got to have timing there's
all kinds of stuff that goes into it
I can watch YouTube videos on how a joke
works you can get a book you can read
that
lots of Comedy books out there
can help you out with how a joke works
or how messing around with someone you
don't really know is just like not
really warranted
I don't really know who that is sorry
yeah I think if you're gonna mess around
with some jokes you just you got to be
funny I think that's a requirement
thank you
whatever
it all matter
all right I don't know how this is gonna
go
but here we are
foreign
that's tough
I hate fighting these guys
man
Vigor is quite literally useless
at this point in the game
I die in three hits maybe two hits every
single time
it doesn't even matter the enemy this is
a [ __ ] summon that was gonna Two Shot
Me by the way
okay well that was more than two
what do you have like ultimate poison
now or something nope all right that'll
work
all right
that's right
foreign
I thought I was out of range to be
honest with you
we can beat him
we can beat him
what enemy is better bats or Birds
or pure strength build
I don't understand the question at this
point now
okay let's run from here
yep that was an l
yeah the Two Soldiers I think kind of
ruined this fight to be honest you know
what out of experimentation let's go
check out what people yell at me about
how I can just go this way
and be fine and not have to run all that
way
now I'm just curious
oh
are you [ __ ] kidding me
no we need him to go to Millennia so we
have to beat him
well now I'm making this longer than it
needs to be or actually I can just jump
down here
go like this
but can I jump from here
yeah yeah
oh skip them
Irby I think that got patched nine
months ago
you could have had a baby in the time
that thing got patched
look at a baby
a little baby
where you jump from the cliff are we not
talking about the same thing
maybe we're talking about something else
foreign
to the pokes very prone to the pokes
foreign
wasn't far enough to the left to dodge
that one
he gets tired right here right
yeah see he's gonna go down
big opportunity
huge opportunity here
it's fine take a little hit on the chief
I swear to God he delayed
[Music]
foreign
I really have to wait on that one that
sucks
foreign
oh okay
so a double roll back is a Dodge there
okay I need two people in the chat to
stop taking over the chat thank you
actually it's more one person
calm down with the chatting put it all
in one message if you could would be
great
[Music]
thank you
find a heel window there we go
why is that so hard to dodge
[Music]
one hit double roll okay one hit double
roll
that works
what's he doing
foreign
doesn't want to get staggered anymore
I take that back
clean
clean
um
that was good
that was very good
that wasn't so bad
we didn't need to skip them
I know how to dodge
we're doing okay
you beat the Poke Lord by poking most of
the time doing
you know Fight Fire with Fire right
depending on what they do
all right
excellent chat
feels good to do that within an hour
or so that's my dog
you guys see Joy she's on the couch
right here
hi joji
redoing
you taking a nap okay
big walk this morning so she is very
tired
she's a big fan of the couch by the way
huge fan
thank you Peter I'm very happy about the
couch
it actually fits really well in here
surprisingly
very surprising
yeah I could adjust the um brightness
but I don't want to have the windows go
you know what I mean
you know have another NPC come in the
chat and be like dude
fix your window
my guy
what's wrong with your window fix it
can you play from the couch
probably not
we're doing pretty good in US
hey dude your window sucks
this very odd messages
I don't know to all the regulars that
are that have been here for like months
and months
do you guys like
there's there's definitely a feeling of
the chat has changed
recently and I'm not sure why
I'm trying to figure it out slowly but
surely trying to figure it out
uh it's just kind of kind of weird
how it changed so quickly
I have Max vigor
besides Buffs I have 99.
yeah I can't play on a couch anymore
either it's just too far away
more people I don't even we don't have
more viewers Stan we actually have less
than when I was streaming on here uh
when we're doing the 100 run we had like
three to four or 500 viewers sometimes
but the chat was always consistent
so overall views we don't don't have
uh that many
guys I feel like we need to we need to
ban soul soldier born
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Leave it to a a
debate
or a vote not a debate a vote
are we Banning Soldier born or not okay
damn
spams the chat
says some really cringe [ __ ]
oh kind of lost right now I'm gonna go
over here real quick
trying to avoid Anastasia
is new yeah I've given him like a couple
warnings man
are you can you run a pole tray or do I
have to
oh god there she is if I just run from
her you know what no I'm not afraid of
you
I have all the Vigor in the world
I will poke you to death
foreign
I mean this is his first day here from
my knowledge and he's already on
probation in my head which is not a good
thing
I'm also thinking about making rules to
put in the description so people can't
just like be like well it's not it's not
a rule is it
I did that on Twitch
it didn't really work but maybe it will
on YouTube I don't
know no problems with her that time no
problems
death counter how have you died no I've
never died I don't die I only live
I'm too good at the game
because YouTube has a rule I don't know
if it pops up in the chat but we could
put it in the description
I should do the same on Discord as well
the goal is to beat the game yep all
remembrances
[Music]
your max HP by 10 and he said that's um
the worm face tree
is that really what it does
I just wanted to get to this spot
there's not a thing to get close to the
Moog which is pretty easy
um you know what let me just go that way
and get The Graces uh and then we can
kind of just decide
yeah I like that Bruno
that's a good idea go to your community
guidelines in the settings and put rules
in it'll pop up for people every live
stream really okay you said Community
guidelines in the settings
all right bet
what's rule number one chat if you had
to guess
yeah we already beat malakath and
everything
we beat maleketh and Godfrey
so we need to beat Moog Melania
and then um radagon eldenbeast
and then we are done
no back seating
I think we could combine like no back
seating into like don't tell me what to
do type of thing
you know oh man I thought it was gonna
let me go without having to fight this
guy but whatever
foreign
[Music]
where is he
can I make this guy fall is there like a
little ledge
oh
wait
wait
that was worth
hahaha
that was a thousand percent worth it man
you're good
that was uh not the correct way to do it
but it is a way to do it nonetheless
don't forget to like the stream I agree
chat
don't forget to like the stream
Alexander thank you for the five dollar
Super Chat I appreciate that very much
thank you
thank you very much
why not just fight them
I don't know man I thought I'd just do
something a little different I thought
it was funny but okay
I thought I'd do something a little
different why not I don't really like
fighting him it's kind of a bleed
machine
but you're right I coulda
I'm sorry I did it differently
careful
careful
really okay
I'm just training myself man
I don't know where all these these NPCs
came from but
um
I need to be thankful that they're even
here
which I am
but holy [ __ ] do some comments piss me
off
like I don't know if I'm weird for this
but whenever I'm in a live stream
I'll like you know if I'm gonna type
something I think
I think a little bit
I think and then I debate on whether or
not to press enter
and if I'm good with all that I press
enter
I don't I don't I don't I don't think
everybody does that
it's gonna go this way we're just trying
to get to the
the side of Grace and then I do want to
go get that uh thing someone was talking
about by the worm face
horns
taurine got [ __ ] up
I don't know why I'm picking up runes
foreign
you already lost 99 of YouTube
commenters at think
yeah
is it really a live stream I don't know
man
depends on
your community I guess
very much depends on the community that
you have
I would I would like it if people
thought before they typed and pressed
enter
for me personally
but I think even pointing this out in
general kind of makes me an [ __ ] so
I'll I will stop
apparently
still surprised to use a torch you know
you know why I use a torch
because way too many people told me to
use a lantern
I yeah
I like actively go against what people
want me to do
it's definitely a toxic trait and I need
to get better at it I'm trying
foreign
so much drama
I'm not entirely sure what drama
like you're aware of but this is not
drama I promise okay
let's go to the worm face and get that
physic
personally I don't know what that is but
I would like to go see
challenge is going good we beat Godfrey
um we have secret Medallion access
obviously so all is well all is going
well
[Music]
[Music]
burnt face is down here right
I think this is one of the most
terrifying areas in the entire game
I don't like going in here it's scary
hmm
okay so everyone reads Soulja Boy born's
message and we're actually gonna start a
poll now
on if he should be banned or not we're
going to go ahead and do that now
not what I would say after getting timed
out
but you said it
was yay so now I know you're looking for
attention and I just want to ban you but
I'm still gonna do this
I'm still gonna do this I'm gonna let
the chat vote
what I'm gonna just do whatever the chat
wants to do that's fine with me
I'll let that run for a minute I don't
know exactly where to go in here
uh by the way so I'm just gonna ride
around
I don't know why you're okay cooling me
man like if you just weren't an [ __ ]
none of this would be happening
it's really easy to avoid there's just
so many other people in the chat who are
doing just fine
and you have actively been a problem
since you have been here
so I don't know what to tell you man
that's it
okay bye here
I think the chat is cool dude and I
think you might be the problem I think
you should start thinking about that
is it down there Chad you said it was by
the tree like by the boss right I don't
really know where the pus is
hmm
It's gotta be back here
no he wasn't just talkative he was
saying weird [ __ ]
oh here we go
this tree
yeah it's got to be this tree
do I have to beat the boss
because there he is
I'm not weird you're disrespectful you
called me weird three times I mean dude
okay I'm done with you bye bye man
I swear to God this some people are just
incapable of understanding that they're
the problem but I guess I'm the streamer
and I'm always the problem okay I'll
fight the boss
Jesus Christ
that's not good
I do not know how to fight worm face
chat
holy [ __ ] this is terrifying
this isn't fair excellent
foreign
for the big attack
let's see how much this does
it just didn't work there we go
decent amount
foreign
that boss is scary dude
okay
let's go check it out
go to the round table actually
um
death hurts yeah
we're fine though
people like Soulja born make me
genuinely uncomfortable he made me
uncomfortable so I asked the chat should
we get rid of him and they said yes so
there you go
all right
what am I doing okay
so we definitely want this enhances
charge attacks that's what really helps
us with that you know our charged attack
um temporarily boosts Max HP
in a mix physic
boost resistance and heals
they're okay today John
we had to ban one person though
what up Logan
that's what the band was for
I mean it was pretty unanimous
hmm
heal status right
I think we used this Boost Max HP
so let's check our HP when we use it oh
I can't actually use it here that's kind
of weird all right
chat
let's let's do all this [ __ ]
foreign
huh
well let's test it all right well that's
a great ruin it up
ruin Arc it up probably shouldn't do
this but here we are
and then we're gonna use the physic just
to see
2988 health
basically 3K
not bad
is it touching you it's touchy it didn't
it's finally touching you chat
the our health bar is actually finally
touching you guys
that's all we wanted
okay hopefully I don't die here and we
lose all our Rune arcs and [ __ ] huzzah
gotcha gotcha gotcha
all right
looks like we're not going there first
is that permanently no
just while the physics active
so it helps us a little bit
we're beyond our threshold for health
man
we're there
and honestly Vigor isn't even that big
of a deal at this late like late stage
we got to get good as hell we gotta but
Dodge absolutely [ __ ] everything
okay where do I get the Crimson Amber
Medallion plus two where do I get that
from chat
because once I do this and get to like
at least melania's boss room I want to
go get that
oh actually I want to go this way first
yeah we're we'll die in two three hits
to Melania no matter what
no The Archers here are actually
demons
okay we already have the capital of Ash
so we could go get that
you see that curved ass [ __ ]
foreign
are you kidding
I really don't want to fall
no way
there ain't no way
okay
good
correct uh attack
we can't level anything else
so we have 99 Vigor and 10 everything
else because we started as a wretch
um the serpent Hunter does not require
any attributes to use because it's
mainly supposed to be used
for Reichard
as like a gimmick weapon but
buy it
if we use this physic that charges hands
charges enhanced attacks
the R2 rtrt or R2 R2 on the serpent
Hunter does like 2500 damage if it lands
very hard to get late game hits with it
but it's like what we can do
otherwise it's just like
a favor plus two is in the area you
access from behind near morgot's Tower
is that true
should have chose Vagabond well then
that would kind of negate the entire
point of the Run wouldn't it
I definitely thought like let's say I
made this entire stream into all these
streams into a video right you know I'd
get comments that are like well you have
18 endurance
you didn't really do only Vigor you know
people are like that man and I'm just
avoiding it
foreign
's favor plus one which we already have
Ukraine
I did not put into endurance I did not
increase the attribute of my endurance
where did you get that from
I just showed it like twice
everything is 10 except for vigor
currently it doesn't work Stan so I'm
gonna have to figure out how to download
all the streams which which can be kind
of rough
pretty much Tech it's extremely
difficult what we're doing because Vigor
doesn't really matter at this point in
the game
like we're gonna get one shot two shot
by pretty much every enemy
we just gotta Dodge like a [ __ ] fiend
and get our big hits in when we can
Crimson two uh is in a beam where you
drop into the sewer from the Ashen
capital
to jump your health over 3000 with the
physic okay cool thank you
nope I always save radagon and Eldon
Beast for last because they're
technically The Last of Us
suck
yep ruin roulette taught us that bigger
doesn't matter I mean we beat the game
with basically no vigor
but we had a lot of attributes and
everything else
mainly strength
I would just call the roon roulette
video it was just a bad build it's it's
quite literally just a bad build that's
what it is
very bad build
concentrated snow field [ __ ] grab
attack does 2400 damage
yeah I think that's meant to just be an
insta kill right
I did beat the game with it but uh
I guess all of the uh
that's a bad sign
that is a bad sign chat
wow
I mean clearly I need more vigor
I am not a fan of the hailing tree
either
um I do like what's what's this next
area called
I always forget the name
oh God
I think the city is really cool not a
huge fan of the Haley tree however
is it Ela field did I say that right
you'll feel
let me go hit this real quick
[Music]
you say it's the worst Legacy dungeon
the Halo tree
[Music]
I think Castle mourn is lame as [ __ ]
like that entire area I think is lame
it's just L feel
you're all saying different things
damn
Alpha l
Phi l
file
interesting name
all right let's check it
excellent
yes
keep going
thank you
that's really [ __ ] unlucky
she would have staggered
nice
why are you not staggering
what the [ __ ]
okay I don't know what's going on here
finally
yeah I use the physic that's why I
wanted to get her to stagger she just
wouldn't
oh
never mind
I just noticed how we never see wild
horses in the game
true
can an amulet or something increase
stagger
I feel like I've heard of one
I kind of just got comboed there nothing
new
these are my talismans
well I don't think taking that was a
good idea
I need to do more jump attacks chat
I've said it before I'll say it again
at certain points
especially in game
your health does not matter
you will die
can we put Vigor only run in the title
no I want people to be confused
[ __ ] it at this point
yeah damage is Bonkers at the end of the
game man it really is
oh that's an attack oh my God
never found damage to gation to be a
factor at all
Trey I had Vigor only run in the title
yesterday and people asked what we were
doing
I don't know how to be more you know
but let's just be vague now at this
point
Vigor only run in the title hey man what
kind of run you doing
all right I'm getting kind of [ __ ]
right now
cool
why are you just jumping
oh my God
[Music]
cool
get me a stagger man
thank you
that's what we want to do
oh God I'm done
foreign
it's gonna be a close one again
oh boy
foreign
[ __ ] you
nice
yeah she went full spam mode there bro
full spammy
okay
to anyone new in the chat
I have only leveled my vigor
only that we have hit Max Vigor so I can
no longer level
calm down about the leveling
number two
the serpent Hunter is fully upgraded
I cannot upgrade it any further
I'm using physics to enhance charged
attacks
I know it doesn't do that much damage
we're waiting for moments to do the big
boy damage which in the end game is very
rare
can we clip that is there clipping on
YouTube
and then to anyone who's interested in
the build we just we just send them to
the clip or something I don't know
what am I gonna do with the runes now
poop them out
I'm gonna go ahead
Joy's moved to the chair
how good is Loretta's sickle I have not
used it personally
I don't think it'll help that much
uh the dragon crest
yes game Runner
I should be using exalted flesh that is
that is true
foreign
you did clip it
um
are you in the Discord
[Music]
put in there and then maybe a mod can
link it
it's in the description if anyone else
wants to join too
the Discord
there we go Stan's got it
uh a Vigor only build horse named
Vigor only my guy
and thank you for the three dollars I
appreciate that
I think I should probably pin that
message instead of Joy's treat fund it's
yeah
what do you think Stan
thank you skill
no I know I was sarcastic I got you bro
why are you rolling through the Scarlet
rot
it only increases the effect of the
Scarlet rot why are you rolling
every time then
I said it that time so now if you say it
you seem weird
what's the hardest boss so far with this
build
um honestly Gideon
is that weird to say man
all right
Gideon
Godfrey was tough but we got it done
oh I know rivers of blood
why are you not using rivers of blood
rivers of blood carried me through new
game plus seven bro why are you not
using rivers of blood
can we get some Frost pots in the chat
members frostbots real quick thank you
raw spots
imagine not being a member
and uh being unable to not
use these beautiful new emotes that we
have now
beautiful new emotes
all right we've made it to
[ __ ] I'm just gonna call her [ __ ]
um
okay
you guys said the Crimson Amber
medallion
you said archery's favor was
here
let's focus on that first look at Let's
Get Er tree's favor plus two
let's get all the things
do I have exalted flesh as well
probably not
nope we're gonna live without it
on a beam when you drop down into the
sewer thank you I I know what you're
talking about now excellent
Flint
okay
[Music]
foreign
Crimson Amber
what are we switching out
do you guys think that we need
ax Talisman could be good
I think we switch this
because I would rather have my recovery
speed to be better than my overall
stamina to be honest with you guys
yeah
yeah
let's throw this on
yep
yeah but it's our only way of doing a
lot of damage Trey so we should have it
there as an option
okay where is er tree's favor plus two
I think last time I asked that a lot of
people said different stuff
yeah we definitely want her three plus
two
we have plus one we need plus two
light load reduce stamina used
oh yeah
we do have medium load
I think we've been doing medium so we're
good
Ashen Landell it's kind of where we
already are morgas Divine Tower but head
towards the capital
um
this way
it's on the Elden ring map somewhere
Maybe ukrainia
drips
you are not wrong
thank you Stan that guy was weird
we've gotten this far Hugh
chat where the heck is it I could have
just come from The Forbidden thing
is it really this way
Head West into the capital from the
grand lift of world down the staircase
the south end of an ash-covered tree
wait what head West into the capital
from the grand lift of rolled
you can't go into the capitol from here
I'm confused
keep going
where the [ __ ] would you go from there
it's not that
get off your damn high horse sir
see what I did there
okay Gideon
Lego Star Wars builds let's get em going
cozy
what's a Lego Star Wars build
thank you horse
appreciate it man
chat I'm confused
why wouldn't I come from the other
direction why would I come from this way
like there I could have gone from Avenue
balcony and been fine
oh you're right it's blocked off now
good point
you're right it's blocked
I've never gone this way from this way
that that makes a lot of sense
yo let's go attack
thanks for becoming a tarnish man
appreciate the membership welcome
welcome WS
W's for Tech
new member baby new member all right
I hear things
I can safely say that I have not been
this way I never thought of going this
way
ever
you guys said it's on a corpse
this is a corpse push
it's down there that makes sense
checking my phone Trey it better not be
[ __ ] feet
uh
you should have a member goal and a
donation goal
[Music]
is that an idea for that trade I'm
working on a UI for that
I like that idea though Trey
but I'm working on a design to help with
like Joy's fund Retreats and then
um our member goal and
um Super Chat goals and stuff like that
okay I thought I'd get a little bit more
leeway there
yeah I gotta sneeze
fat where the [ __ ] is it man
yeah
there's two of them
ridiculous
It's gotta be this
get me out give me out give me out huge
chat big
foreign favor plus two boom
there it is
Corn's dead LOL
all right
chat
mooger Melania
hello
yo what up Aaron thanks for becoming a
great Rune good to have you here welcome
welcome
W's in the chat for Aaron I'm seeing a
lot of mugs let's do it
seeing a lot of moogs
let's go
yeah how many likes we have by the way
how many likes are we at right now
163
let's try and get that to 200 chat let's
go
let's get to 200 likes chat
let's get it
yeah I'm 99 vigor fully figured out
thank you again Aaron in Tac
any tips for getting to level 500
kill bosses
and uh
level up
kill bosses level up
Twisted let's go
it's wasted with the five gifted huge
W's in the chat for Twisted
constantly giving memberships here thank
you man
thank you very much
you should probably beat the game malwak
and then um do New Game Plus
I'm watching the cutscene
I like the cutscene
thank you again twisted and if you if
you get a gifted
from Twisted make sure to say thank you
those will start rolling out now
buddy got one very nice
buddy dead waifu and star stalker I am
Melania
blade of Nicola Drake
W's in the chat for Trey guys
five gifted members himself
thank you man I appreciate that thank
you
it's a Mogan Tom
thank you twisted and thank you Trey
very much
W's all around
dearest I have a feeling we are going to
be here for a very long time
let's get it twisted
yep enjoy the emotes and make sure to
say thank you to whoever you got a sub
from
uh Tennessee I did forget to put moog's
thing on but I don't think that's gonna
be a major problem to be honest with you
[Music]
foreign
right
[Music]
that one gets me a lot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
sucks
I'm actually don't know how I got hit by
that
I'm getting muged right now I'm
literally getting mugged
after fighting flawlessly
definitely getting moogs
we gotta get the physics
yeah it's mine
I just got mugs so [ __ ] hard dude
I think I already got it by the way
oh I should have gone to the thingy oh
well
actually this is somewhat better
I wish this spear turned into a floppy
serpent that could whack things
that would be kind of cool
didn't I already get it chat
I didn't
that was another playthrough
all right let's go get it
oh that's right that's right it's this
one
correct
I love the lore between Melania Nikola
and Moog it's all very interesting I I
hope there's more to come
foreign
tree cheetah spawns now
[Music]
I gotta say this at least once a stream
but how the [ __ ] did God of War win best
musical track when we're listening to
this right now I just don't understand
hello
this is just [ __ ] background music
foreign
I almost thought about making a fully
dedicated video about that chat but I
think it's too far gone at this point
I think I did enough in that uh that one
video I had the of the game awards
I did think of doing a fully dedicated
video to why God of Wars um musical
store score award
was um completely
taken from Eldon ring
yeah it's pretty good I'm not saying God
of War's music is bad
at all
but you know what I mean did I even put
it on the physics chatter am I just that
stupid
it doesn't matter
we all know the answer to that anyway
they had the same theme from their last
game that's a lot of the point as well
that's a lot of my point as well
temporarily Boost Max HP yeah we got to
switch that one out because we want to
do more damage
well
trying to think is there any point
yeah I can stagger him I can stagger him
okay
does smoke stagger in stage two I think
it's pretty rare
that he does
very rare
I would like to think my unorthodox
Rabbi Bill Clinton thank you
I don't think God of War won more Awards
than Elden ring I think Elden ring won
more Awards overall
or around the same I'm not sure
the shackle is useless I'm not getting
the shackle
thank you
all right
you backing up man
that's why
[Music]
foreign
attack
[Applause]
patience chat
[Music]
why am I not getting a staggered
keep backing up
shouldn't have spoke
oh I hate that attack
yeah it's probably too much time in
between hits
thank you
thank you
not entirely sure how that one didn't
hit
[Music]
[Music]
Jesus Christ
thank you
he went from the most passive stage one
ever to the most aggressive stage two I
think I've seen him have
yeah the Tombstones didn't help I'm
gonna throw this on early chat
okay
man that backhand is just really
annoying me right now
[Music]
dude he threw that [ __ ] at his [ __ ]
feet
my role just literally didn't work I
don't know
it's such a bad attempt guys
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chill man
dude
walk with
dude I got in the gaming Zone
did y'all see that [ __ ]
I got in the gaming Zone dude
oh my God
I still get hit by a lot of stuff but I
feel like I've kind of mastered Moog in
a lot of ways we've done so many
challenges where Moog was such a giant
like step for us
and now
we got him now here's the real [ __ ]
problem
okay guys everybody everybody
go to the bathroom
I'm gonna take joy to go potty
do all the things
I'm gonna go to the bathroom I'm gonna
get more water I'm literally gonna make
another coffee I'm gonna do all the
things
Everybody Take Five
prepare yourselves for this
everybody get your Frost pots out now
foreign
get him out now
get them while they're hot
get them going
anytime you all see some Rando in here
telling me to use frostbots you know
what to do
why does she have to be so cool man
She's So Dope but I hate her
I dreamed for so long
flesh was dull gold and my blood rotted
I don't know why she fights us either
whoops after corpse left in my way do
you guys think she'd maybe have lost her
mind here hasn't really thought of that
before it's returned like maybe she's
just speaking [ __ ] gibberish here I
don't know
who's she trying to prove this to
and maybe she's like telling us heed my
words I've never been defeated maybe
it's because she's actually low-key
insecure
she might be insecure because she lost
to radon to be honest with you she
[ __ ] lost
Ty
and I have never known defeat
let's go
nice delay [ __ ]
okay
bad
yeah I know she's tarnished chat but
I guess she doesn't know who she's
talking to
that was a bad attempt
foreign
I don't know drips
[Music]
foreign
that's definitely [ __ ] delayed right
[Music]
just did it again
what'd you find Logan
delay
why am I here why is she talking
wait what oh [ __ ]
oh God
oh let's go Logan
thank you for the 10 gifted memberships
dude I literally [ __ ] thought she was
talking
like why is she talking again
huh
[Music]
's in the chat for Logan please
big W's
freaking Legend thank you man
oh definitely waterfowl right
yeah yeah yeah
God chat what is her [ __ ] hell fat
man
foreign
ly High
hello
foreign
that every time actually
make sure to thank uh Logan if you got a
gifted from him man thank you again
hell yeah
[Music]
foreign
wow
foreign
dude this [ __ ] sucks
clearly a bad attempt
nah this ain't a bigger check anymore
man this is a meme
[ __ ] it
take it
I can't I gotta remember that I can tank
it
even if I am too close so I can get out
but that wouldn't have been very good
Melania did not win game of the year
hello Elden rink did Melanie is a
[ __ ] meme
I'm thinking of that ligma
I might have to get really good at
parrying chat to make this even possible
I don't know if this is what we're doing
is possible
we either do that
foreign
I have to play Perfect
like I can't make a mistake or I die
not that I die
we can do it
it's just really hard
I don't even think Perry's are going to
be that good
to be honest
because
our reposts don't do that much damage
can't make a mistake
yeah anyone telling me to use a
different weapon I I quite literally
can't
weapons require things
weapons require attributes to use I have
only leveled vigor
tell you what if let me solo her arrives
in the chat
and says yo what up I will summon him in
and I will let him kill her for us
that'll be super Epic
he has been in the chat
three times
so it's not out of the question
[Music]
we must summon the legend himself
foreign
foreign
got hit by the first got staggered into
the others that's pain
I I feel like I've been fighting here
for 10 minutes and her health like is
that far down
okay it's kind of weird
she gets up so fast we kind of can't
even use our charge attacks
[Music]
I think the charge just kind of useless
on her
foreign
foreign
that's [ __ ] right get owned
I spoke I spoke out loud and that
happened it's incredible absolutely
incredible
foreign
foreign
I mean it takes too long for me to
recover from that attack so I can't do
that either
if she's below 70 HP she can use
waterfowl whenever she wants
so
I I already want to call it early chat I
don't
I don't think we can do it like this it
it quite literally takes too long to
kill her
it just takes too long
I don't know what else I can do
loose physical attacks
we've won
yeah I don't have the damage I could
just try and get so [ __ ] good
that I never get hit but we know with
Melania that she doesn't fight fair it's
her AI is quite literally broken it's
been proven
to do that
it's it's just too little damage
yeah everything you guys are saying I
can't do there are there are things
there are requirements used for weapons
in the game and I don't have the
requirements because of the challenge
I almost want a skipper I I hate her
dude
I hate her
I think she's one of the worst design
bosses in all of Gaming
I will fight to the ends of the Earth
with that one
and I've already done my [ __ ] Melania
grind you all saw it in the last
challenge
I did it
I was here for six hours
188 attempts
Non-Stop
ask me if I want to do that again
I don't
I don't want to do it again
[Music]
pull it after this
no I can't use Source seals they
increase the attributes of other
they increase attributes other than
bigger so I can't use it
[Music]
foreign
her her pulleys just doesn't make sense
it's just stupidly broken
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[ __ ]
[Music]
shouldn't have called you that
was my fault
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
I mean I I was full focused there guys
doing as good as I could got hit by one
little thing and it was kind of over
all right we all think
y'all said to do a poll
democracy it is
I was fighting her really well there man
really well
I'm surprised y'all are saying no
I'm surprised
yeah
yeah I honestly that's a good question
to ask homie
do you guys even like watching someone
struggle against Melania
maybe if the build had some viability
I mean let's
I know y'all are saying no but I want to
try a couple things before we totally
say no okay I I will try a few things so
y'all voted no
so that's fine
not gonna lie I couldn't watch the whole
six hour fight I don't know how you
could
I don't know how you could
um
let me try something
I'm not using Frost pots it's not gonna
make a [ __ ] difference
I'm not really worried about the the
waterfowl
annoying
I don't even think they're that good
where's gostock
is he still stomping on that bitch's
head
or do I already have the buckler Shield
the result everyone wanted me to skip
them
it's not here I definitely killed him
uh I should have it then maybe I didn't
go to the right spot
summon let me solo her
I wish
yeah I think I said all right somebody
become a member and I'll and I'll kill
him and somebody did
actually someone gifted five I do
remember that
it needs 13 decks even to Parry
all right
do you guys think this would be fair
I can put on the source Shields
no
just for her
I yeah I think that goes against the
rules I I don't want to break all the
rules bro
it increases other things other than
vigor so it literally would just be it
would no longer be a Vigor only run
I think that's the one thing I can't do
what about a mimic
or is the run invalidated with a mimic
as well
challenges still valid since you never
leveled any other stats
let's let's try the mimic
um
I can go up this way
mimic doesn't increase anything that's
true
but a lot of people see using a summon
as like
um
breaking the rules
of like any challenge
double the life double the despair
do they do mimics in Rune level one runs
at least in that you can use the uh
the sore seals
well that's an interesting take
so if they're allowed in Rune level one
to use the sore seals why can't I use it
bigger only
that changes that rule
because it's bigger only
well for them it's Rune level one only
but they are not technically level one
to the same standard that we would be
only leveling vigor you know what I mean
oh what'd you say Irby I'm sorry I
missed it
you get up here
foreign
you guys see what I'm saying though
gear is not the same as leveling a stat
no I did want to turn this entire
challenge into a video
um somehow
so I don't want to have people get mad
at me
I don't like it when people get mad at
me
all right
sorcile is valid in every other
challenge run so I don't know why this
would be different I guess just because
we've called it Vigor only
but technically we are not
purposely increasing our attributes
you know
summoning a mimic is using your Vigor
right
maybe do the other bosses first
it's not how I roll bro
that's not how I roll
radagon
is last
wait why is she not sitting over here
yet
it depends on the wording only level
Vigor versus only increase vigor
both would be Vigor only
would they
why is she not going over there
and actually I'm not gonna lie to you
guys
I didn't do all the dialogue
um a mimic is pretty much useless
against Melania I I agree with that
basically useless
it does distract her
quite a bit
I haven't gotten any ghosts
you're also mad on your level because
the soft caps are bigger so basically
you're like level 60.
60 all right let's do a poll
let's do a pull I don't want to summon
online I don't I don't want to do the
online thing
seals
yes or no
we've been doing a lot of democracy so
we're gonna keep doing some democracy
vote now
use mimic with heaviest armor but not to
overweight him
summon online first to keep the Run
valid okay that is out the window yeah I
don't want to do online anything
you should use seals for her only bushy
breaks his rules sometimes if the fight
is too hard so if he does it you can do
it too
hmm
I do like me some bushy
black knife Tish will do a lot of damage
only give the mimic pots
if you do seals it's not bigger only see
I don't understand that
if in my argument to that Joshua like
I've said a couple times
is in Rune level one runs everyone I've
seen they are allowed to use seals
which technically does not make them
level one
so why in this challenge can I not do
that
the rule is to level Vigor only
right their rule is well is to not level
at all and yet they still use Source
seals do you get what I'm saying
that doesn't change your level in the
status menu yes it does it literally
increases your attributes
it it increases your attributes correct
I I know it's my challenge but I want to
do what the chat wants me to do
no the actual level is literally
increased
attributes yes but not the Rune level
that's literally what we've been talking
about since the start
I like the rule
is I don't go in here and use runes to
level anything other than vigor
to increase the attribute point of
anything other than vigor
and they do the same for roon level ones
I'm not understanding like I don't mean
the stat but your player level
now now I'm confused
hmm
your rules say to not increase any
attributes but Vigor they stay at level
1 because Source seals don't count as
more levels
it does though doesn't it or am I just
not remembering that riot
bye cat
it doesn't
it just adds stats
where
unlike uh the side the other view here
right
but we've been boosting stats with
stamina
with talismans and and [ __ ] like that
right
so should I have not been using that the
entire time
I'm confused
were those Buffs these talismans right
here
Green Turtle talismans raises stamina
recovery speed
vastly raises maximum HP
raises maximum HP stamina and equip load
so what would you use them for
I mean 83 it's so weird 83 percent of
chat said yes to to seals but as I'm
looking at chat most of y'all are saying
that I can't use it what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna go get the seal and just see
the difference I guess
everybody hold
I think we're saying you can everyone
I'm looking at saying no
most
it's like a loud minority I guess
I'm a very gullible person chat so when
when people are like well it means this
and it does this I'll be like what
really even though I kind of like
have played the game a lot I'll still
always question myself
because we definitely found that [ __ ]
Millennia there was gonna be stupid
really hard
yep I'm testing it out we're testing
currently testing
okay
so I'm gonna look at let's just [ __ ]
with the ax Talisman and go to the seal
it literally increases the levels of
endurance strength index and would have
increased
uh
my vigor
you can see it on the right it increases
them the 15.
so they do that in roon level once
on the right side character status
doesn't increase the level how were you
looking at that and saying it doesn't
increase it doesn't increase the level
sure
but they're still increasing the
attributes
correct I did not level them I only
leveled Vigor this is just a sore seal
stat but not level holy [ __ ] do you guys
not see his attributes as levels
as the same [ __ ] thing
they're the same thing
your promise was to only level up vigor
which is what I did are you saying Trey
that if I do this I'm not doing that
I'm confused
they're not the same thing
this sucks man
do you see my point fear
Melania isn't a remembrance boss
she is though
right
Is Molina not a remembrance boss
yeah she is so why did someone just say
she's not holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
well game Runner I'm I'm questioning it
now because Melania is quite literally
impossible without some upgrades
and now I'm questioning it for Melania
and the rest of our run to be honest the
entire time
because of the Rune level 1 players
you couldn't have used Talisman as sword
seals for the Roulette Challenge because
you weren't randomly uh decided but you
did
you didn't hold yourself through
standard before don't do it now
I did use these tray I'm pretty sure I
did
where's my dog
wow I got her this big ass couch and
she's on the bed
he's on the Bed Man
I'm high as [ __ ] right now good for you
dude
nice
that's what I'm saying Cole if I'm able
to use
stamina upgrades that increase my
literal stamina attribute
or status or whatever the [ __ ] you all
want to call it
why can't I use a sore seal
I love how chaotic my chat is right now
I [ __ ] love this I feel like my chat
moves as fast as like uh
somebody with uh 20 000 viewers it's
awesome
I'm all about it
so that means the people that are here
committed they're in it bro
yeah I'd be able to use the buckler if I
use this tear down our democracy Jake I
mean you all said I could 85 percent of
people said yeah use it man
okay Jack Hughes the soul seals SL1 runs
use it you can too that's what I'm
saying you use the things that help you
didn't break your challenge
and Finn with the five gifted let's go
baby
all right chat I need everyone to reset
everybody reset and just Spam W's give
me some W's okay we're gonna calm down
we're gonna calm down real quick y'all
are all about it though I love it man I
appreciate the energy
Finn thank you for the two bucks and the
five gifted I really appreciate you
thank you reset yourselves okay
let's all calm down and we did hit our
goal when
chat
thank you Angel with the three months
thank you as well good to have you back
sir
all right
now here's the next thing I want you all
to do
I want you to look to the person in chat
to your left
and I want you to say I love you
and then I want you to look to your
right in chat
and I want you to say
I love this stream
this spread love
fall calm down
because I need you all to remember
that this is a video game
okay
not that big of a deal
it's not that big of a deal it's okay
I'm
I don't know why I'm doing this
okay
[Music]
I am Melania
blade of Nicola uh oh I got a 15a here
that says sawziel is legit that is 15 to
Joy's treat fund from Anonymous thank
you very much that's very very kind of
you
thank you thank you thank you
15 that's a lot
I'm gonna
um upgrade all the UI chat so next time
we stream tomorrow
everything's gonna looks different
besides the chat so hopefully uh you're
cool with that
I've been working on
um different designs for the stream that
makes it look better
yeah he said it and paid for it I no
Trey everything's good bro
see how I'm changing up the vibe real
quick love is good
love is good guys thank you all for the
support I'm glad you care this much okay
time us out please all right
okay
I'm gonna go ahead and say that we can
use it
I think we should
I think it makes sense to the Run we did
it in the last challenge where we only
were supposed to spin the wheel and we
used sore seals as well there
um this will help us get the buckler so
that we can Parry her and all that [ __ ]
no I'm not ending the stream I'm still
here
we're gonna use it
um I think it goes with the rules if you
disagree with that then you disagree
with that okay
okay
if you disagree with it
I'm sorry
and uh I hope you can forgive
what are we gonna switch it with
probably this because we can't really do
charged attacks
um
we probably don't need this either
should we go get America's Source seal
as well
right Frost pots Frost pots yep
get that doggo some treats and slap on
that sauce yellow
you got it Tootie for the six dollars it
I don't know what happened to my voice
there oh my God I think the mic broke
totally not a voice crack uh 2T thank
you for the 6.90 I appreciate it the
Joy's treat fund thank you guys
hi Lupa
okay I'm gonna ban you
nope we don't we don't [ __ ] around with
that goodbye that's just weird
yeah the mic totally broke there Tootie
thank you for the 690.
nope I'd banned him I banned his ass bye
okay
uh did you guys say yes
to America's seal or no is it not even
useful for us
dude we are 30 members away from 400 as
well that's kind of nuts
yeah I don't think we need that actually
yeah it gives us less damage resistance
okay
let us simply go see the difference okay
is that my joji oh alone
hi
yeah we don't need to use America I I
forgot kind of what it did
okay guys we don't need star scourges
because we don't need that
don't need that
all right here we go why are you nudging
my chair
with your snoot
you know a bunch of people just gave you
money Joy he's here to say thank you by
the way let's get some joys in the chat
get some joists
you get used to this again
why are you so aggressive
oh God
I gotta get in the flow
currently not in the flow
it's made a really big difference huh
our damage is still ass
look she just got it all back too by
hitting me
foreign
wow
um
get dragon Crest Great Shield didn't I
grab that
uh on my way to God's skin now
yeah let me uh where was the buckler
chat I I so I killed gostuck and I got
his Bell bearing did I just not turn it
in maybe
the buckler is not in the Holland tree
hey League tree
sorry
well there it is what the [ __ ] I have to
go directly to it interesting
train joy to beat Melania for you
Joy
you do you think you could beat Melania
she's wagging her tail I don't know if
you guys can see her or not
go lay down go on
they won't see you go lay down
go
oh my goodness
yeah I know it's a Perry Shield all
right there she is
in all the pets
you all lay down go lay down
not there okay
okay
yeah it's an eight by eight by eight
Peter it's a [ __ ] huge couch
huge couch
honey
but she's so cute oh my God
he's so cute
you're okay
um Joy it is not time to do any of the
things that you are begging me for right
now so I need you to go lay down
it's way too early to do any of this
stuff go lay down go
go okay you can lay right there if you
want
I get scared of running over her foot
I love JoJo Queen
all right chat uh how long is it gonna
take me to get good at pairing Melania
haven't ever tried it
and honestly I think it's the only thing
I do until I repost her over and over
again
no joke
glad we moved on from the rules chat
remember this is a boss we voted to skip
just be grateful for the bonus content
and worry about more important things
like liking the stream right
have y'all liked the stream yet
Graham thank you for the 420. I
appreciate that man thank you very much
thank you thank you
okay
okay
here we go
I don't know what attacks are payable
but here we go
I doubt that one is
yeah I have to Parry her three times
right
what about phase two
excellent first try on the Perry
there's one
foreign
I doubt that one's a Perry we already
got one though I feel like this is good
I just tried to Parry her [ __ ] foot
foreign
I got two
what the f she's so [ __ ] blind
so scared
I feel like when she does that step
and I doubt this one is right I don't
know I should try
The Shield is not useless
if I can find the windows to Parry her
then on the third knock I can repost her
and we do that over and over again until
she dies
calling it useless
Joy went to the couch
also I am so happy with
this couch
just so you all know
[ __ ]
dude I got two though
see that that was a quick one two
oh
I got a quick one too you see that
that was good
was good
very nice
hey it's potato
hopefully we don't have recurrence of
last time don't give me memories of the
last type of Tater and thank you for the
two bucks man I appreciate it
was I too late
can I Parry her grab
[Music]
it was too late it was too late
definitely
foreign
God I'm so [ __ ] bad
no
all right
[Music]
her Poise recovery is really high you
have to keep pairing her in a short
amount of time or else she will not be
reposed oh no really
should I just stay close to her
and she'll just do the attacks we want
ah
I went too early
I I don't know what I did wrong there
[Music]
man I got two quick ones and then
why are the Perry Perry windows so weird
in Souls games
I gotta learn Chad I gotta learn we're
learning right now
at least this is more fun than trying to
beat her straight up
is my character even
the last two times I've tried to Parry I
don't I literally don't even see it
okay
I'm gonna try
that was a mistake
video
blade oh my God we got one
my chat is lovely everybody's spam Joy
spread Joy
Joy all around
my chat is not toxic uh if they're being
toxic to you that probably means you
said something stupid
I'm thinking about a mimic soon but I
want to keep trying this
foreign
what am I doing wrong there
do that one
I think I'm too early
just gotta learn
[Music]
this is weird
I mean we gotta learn right
foreign
[Music]
no way my chat is wrong can we get some
NPCs in the chat
NPCs
I'm seeing a lot of them
I look at the chat and I see maybe two
three NPCs
can I Parry that [ __ ]
oh yeah
okay
a lot of damage there guys
[Laughter]
man
is this consistent
can't use that remember Traveler
probably can
I think I'm just a little early
sometimes
foreign
right right moon sorceries right right
get some Frost spots in the chat please
raw spots
y'all saw that
Friday at four [ __ ]
foreign
I just gotta get I gotta get all the
thingies
all the the instances of what can happen
when I'm literally just standing in
front of her waiting to for her to hit
me foreign
I got a Snapchat
okay
is top G weird every time every time
I've looked at top G's being kind of a
dick
I don't know what to do though I haven't
seen it enough myself
I have an itch on my nose
okay
okay
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
okay let me reread top G's comment just
now chat okay you guys ready I'm
literally gonna scroll up and I'm gonna
hide up he's gone he retracted it
Brad did it you [ __ ] incel inbred
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
got it before you did you [ __ ]
you're bad you stupid
oh I just caught you red-handed you
[ __ ] doofus
oh what an idiot what an idiot bro oh my
God that's funny
I live in a highlight he's like
literally
literally my God what a weirdo
[Music]
damn
foreign
[Music]
if I take my if I two-hand my sword
there will I do more damage
I could Parry that
I'm scared of it though
I'm out of the flow I'm out of Flow
State out of Flow State
at a flow state
it doubles this
I should probably get good at just like
going to that really quick just like
going two hand and then stabbing her
that was funny though huh
is there anything that it can that can
increase
um well [ __ ]
but I don't have it
um
is there anything that can increase my
thing
uh
my repose
foreign
okay
[Music]
I like when she does the side step
not bad
I need to I need to start hitting that
one
wait who said top G lives on now try so
this guy earlier chat hurry up I
remember your name because it's so
stupid
um I was fighting I was literally in the
middle of fighting Godfrey at the
beginning of the stream and he says
do you just go through the fog gate
because his name's hurry up
got him
got him
oh I hate that attack
don't tell Jake to hurry up
that's not what I said did we ban more
people today than we ever have
in one stream for sure
do you guys think it's me
you think it's my fault
I mean I do do the Banning but I feel
like all of these bands are deserved
why am I doing that
living on the edge yeah
your space you control he gets to be
here yeah but I give them attention and
that makes other people come out of like
maybe they weren't chatting they're like
oh wait if I am cringe then this guy
will talk to me
which is really weird
yeah
don't answer that he'll ban you
just gave me a bad vibe
that comment just gave me a bad vibe
straight up
got it that that one is tough guys
comes out pretty quick
I didn't do the thingy
foreign
[Music]
you know
what it is
I'm I'm on clearly living in The Matrix
I'm a part of The Matrix
and the Matrix is giving me these cringe
idiots
uh making it harder for me to get my
Bugatti
if they don't contribute to the Bugatti
from then I don't want it
foreign
[Music]
what did I do wrong I hit the button
blade
I hit the button bro
I hit the button I can't do his accent
yeah traveler I've seen you say that
like six times man
what you're saying is also just not true
which is why I've been ignoring it
well actually it could be true
but saying something multiple times is
probably the least efficient way
to get me to do the thing you want me to
do
come on Jake I need to start getting
confident with the parries I'm gonna
start going for some [ __ ]
blade of
me it's almost like almost almost every
attack
is is periable I'm learning and then
once I get into a flow state
um we might get the stage two
I'm I'm close to uh
going with our initial vote
and just saying that this is dominant
possible and we shouldn't do it anybody
like we should just go to radagon and
and the Elven beast and be done I hate
this fight with a burning passion but
the pairing is fun
foreign
I just see my character not do it
um
just a little ass
[Music]
I have to see that one coming bro I have
to
foreign
it is torturous
it is torturous
I do gotta get in the zone what is an
NPC in the chat somebody who says
something that's like
I thought of this while in bed last
night chat I was like
what if every time somebody in the chat
just says something that's npc-like I
would say
hey uh username Do you have a questline
Do you have a questline
in the game
Oh that's oh you don't that's crazy bro
I thought you're an NPC
hey what Stan what
I think I missed your quest line bro
God [ __ ] that attack man holy [ __ ]
oh bro that's cringe dude
it's cringe man
I thought you were amazing yeah my
amazing voice acting right exactly
come on Jake
get your head out of your butthole man
traveler have to be 15.
no I'm kidding I'm kidding him kidding
don't joke about age by the way
very close to a band
why can't I get that overhead chat
what's wrong with me
hate that I can't do it
[Music]
come on if I can get the timing of that
overhead I can do it
I believe in myself
it's also kind of fun to Parry
it's fun I'm having fun
I'm having a good time it's already
three o'clock I've been streaming for
four hours
oh no
hmm
I could do a I can do a later walk with
joy since the weather is so [ __ ] but I'd
have to take her out to go pee
I hate you
the [ __ ] overhead man
foreign
I've only been doing parries so that
doesn't help our situation either
can I Parry her stage two
two
foreign
[ __ ] you
[Music]
the [ __ ] was that
foreign
it's quite literally just the overhead
it's the only one that I'm scared of
I don't know what it is about it man it
comes out so [ __ ] quick
no I I I can feel it skim I I just have
not timed it correctly yet
I can feel it though
you can Parry your Parry oh she can
Parry My Perry
oh boy
that'd be bad
I felt like I deserved that one
[ __ ] you
why did they design this game to have
Vigor be completely useless in the end
game what the [ __ ] is
is that not weird have we talked about
this kind of dude what were they
thinking like what if someone was just
like yeah dude I'm gonna have
all the Vigor in the world and I'll
never die and I'll be super strong two
hits from Melania and you're dead like
what the [ __ ]
what the it's so strange
come on dude
I want to be able to Parry that
I don't think I can
definitely can't Parry that
[Music]
damn bro
share this
I feel like what if I skip Melania and I
want to make this entire thing into a
video I feel like I'm gonna get so much
[ __ ]
for not doing Melania
foreign
did not make a damage difference to be
too Handy by the way
foreign
foreign
knew it
blade
maybe I can be the guy in the challenge
run category where I'm like Melania is
broken and I refuse to do her
until she is fixed
maybe I can be that guy
I think I'd just be a [ __ ] at that
point
foreign
I literally wimp out
yeah maybe it's like our lore reason to
just not mess with her because you know
we just don't want to mess with her
you know
it can be a part of the AGT Jake lore
that'd be weird
stop wimping out man
foreign
it's literally just the overhead
it's so weird
she has full health
the [ __ ] overhead
[Music]
yeah we got rad has gone seal at least
Laura is you've served your time and
you're done now
I really did didn't I I really did serve
my time
come on dude
there's some that I'm like dude I
totally did
get the Perry
oh I just had an idea
I just had an idea what if every time in
our challenge run
instead of fighting her we respect to
let me solo her and then after we're
done with her we respect back to where
our character was before
foreign
like same build and everything
or as close as we can to her
I don't even think I can Parry fast
enough on that one
I'm getting kind of good
except except for the overhand
not very good at that one
like am I not
it's pretty good
can I um Parry her waterfowl by chance
I cannot got it
foreign
why do I do that
the kick also drained all my stamina
just did it again
I'm in full Parry mode
man bro
okay where where's the where's the
repost damage increase thing where is
that I'm gonna go get it I'm gonna do it
chat I don't care
I don't care I'm gonna do it I I I can't
I gotta do it
where is it volcano Manor I think
someone said
I'll throw it on
let me cook let's go I'm ready
after God skin Noble okay what what part
I'll go there
here
near the way gate to Reichard
uh
uh okay I guess I can go there
just let me cook boys
this could be our
this could be our way to just beat
Melania no matter what thing we have
going on
if I can just learn how to Parry the
[ __ ] out of her it doesn't even matter
what challenge we're doing
unless it's just no parries
behind a key door next to the snake
priest with the egg hat oh my God
a key door
near there's another key door near them
I know of one on the other side
let me shank her
fairies can trivialize The Crucible
Knights too yeah
Rue dude
it's just the one
so it's inside uh not this door but the
next one on the left up the stairs
one door you mentioned on the other side
and I believe we already opened
up okay where
is it that thing
if so how do I get over there
did I already [ __ ] up
did that
yes okay we don't know uh okay
oh I see
how do I get over there
oh did I already mess it up man
foreign
I can't go back up there
[ __ ] it just kill me oh okay
okay
yo let me just go ahead and grow wings
and fly sure
let me let me just do that
just real quick
yep remember to leave a like
if mode can grow wings so can you
uh I don't know if that's how that works
but it would be kind of cool
foreign
I won't cap with you on that one there
sir
it's kind of annoying that I have to run
this far back
all I did was jump down on one ledge and
it completely locked me out of where I
wanted to go
foreign
yes I am the demigod of pure vigor
you will have to jump to the right and
not down on the cages okay
if only I had a lantern then I would
have been able to see
let's go with that
that's what I was saying game Runner
that's what I'm saying bro
okay
this ledge right here
gotta be
there's another [ __ ] door here
he's a little snakey boy
I don't think that's the same Albin orc
is it
it
was
there it is
dagger talisman
let's see the difference in that
you'd be looking mad cute today not
gonna lie
thanks
let's get it
thanks
I am a Cowboys fan
foreign
let's see the difference
282
it's not a lot but it's something
we take what we can get
[ __ ] overhead Swing Man
yep there it is again there it is again
Jake gets the babes all right tell me
how you all think about this
so I got a snap text earlier right I got
a snap text
she said so I asked her or we were
talking and she goes
tomorrow's Friday woo
said very true did you want to hang out
and she said maybe I have to do some
homework school full-time and working
full-time and I'm overwhelmed
hmm
that's pain man
break up with her we're not dating we we
did go on one date
but she does work and go to school
full-time
I gotta figure out this [ __ ] overhand
man
oh my God
tell her you're a full-time gamer
soft exit she be lying
don't be so passive you should say I'm
going to the bar at time wanna come with
oh so you you're saying I need to be
like aggressive
I'm not really that way bro
if she wants to she'll tell you
yeah I think I gotta let her ask me on
the next date
you know what I mean
come on
[ __ ] Melania bro
girls like definitive things I mean no
[ __ ] bro no [ __ ] but if she like
actually can't then it doesn't matter
you're such a good friend
there it is
I'm not going to take advice from my
chat I just won't
but I'm putting it out there
foreign
okay
what what the [ __ ] did she just do
foreign
back to full health I guess
he's not huh
that pissed me off
[Music]
whatever practice
foreign
how am I missing that window
a blade
foreign
you guys notice how all I said were the
messages
I didn't say how I felt about it or
nothing you all are assuming like she
didn't say no so I'd be cool about it
bro
like it's all good
I ain't pressed
foreign
[Music]
you must be heartbroken in the Pressed
good thing you have Melania therapy
right right
exactly exactly
exactly
there is something funny about an idea
of fighting Melania and dealing with
relationship issues guys it's not an
issue
there's no relationship issue we went on
a date Monday night and we had a great
time
but she works and goes to school full
time
it's hard to go on dates
it's legit hard man
foreign
first overhead
Harry
I want to know if I can Parry that but
I'm always too scared to do so
okay
there it is a metaphor attack yeah
so everything is still good with y'all I
mean yeah we talk every day
so it's not like she's ghosting me and
then I have to be like double textured
to even get an answer on if she wants to
go on another date you know what I mean
but here's where I'm at in my life
when it comes to dating
foreign
if she wanted to
[Music]
she would make time
don't you think
this [ __ ] boss
God she sucks
and yeah you go to school you go to work
full time
I know you're busy
but if you wanted
you would make time
God I [ __ ] hate the overhead
this stream has never been family
friendly that is hilarious
foreign
I guess
I I don't know what to do about that
attack it literally comes so fast I
quite literally don't know what to do
I'm gonna test
cannot Parry it I'm pretty I'm pretty
sure you can't
um
yes sure
here's the other part chat she's also
said that she just got out of a
long-term relationship about a month ago
so I ain't pushing nothing
I think that's important context
that's very important context
what the [ __ ]
there's like a year relationship or
something
[Music]
the other part of this though is that
I've known this girl for a very long
time
so I don't see it as a red flag
[ __ ]
a year is long term I would say so a
year is a long time
[Music]
scaled one to ten how much do you really
like her
um
I mean I've known her a long time
a really long time
so
it
a lot I'll say a lot
foreign
but I'm not rushing anything
I
the overhead is literally the only thing
I'm thinking about God damn it bro
going on 11 years and have a
six-year-old kid that's so different
like you're literally probably married
and you've had kids and that's a totally
different thing if you've been with
someone for like over a year I would say
that's a long-term relationship that's a
year of your life
it's a long time
yep
[Music]
foreign
why am I not getting that one
come on
foreign
I'm giving this a few more tries chat
and then I'm just I'm gonna call it on
Millennia for the rest of my life
the requirements for this boss are
literally meme-like I'm over it
all right have fun playing League of
Legends that sounds awful
foreign
oh my God
why do I think I can carry that
now I'm just missing that one
consistently
she's got full [ __ ] Health again like
what's the point
yeah relationships kind of suck Finn I I
agree with you there
seems like the Perry isn't worth it
it's worth it if I can just consistently
not [ __ ] up over and over again
blade of Michela
let's record Second Wind let's get this
[ __ ] what are the requirements for the
misery chord Big Bad Brad and thank you
for the tender Joys treat fund
I want to get this [ __ ] I do
I appreciate that Brad thank you
gotta remember the requirements though
you can overhead
foreign
[Music]
dude I just hate her bro I hate her
you can't be beaten if you enjoy
suffering I know it seems like I enjoy
suffering chat but I do not I don't like
to suffer
hi baby hold on Joy
give me a couple more tries here honey
I know I I'm close to saying heck with
this boss but [ __ ] man
I had one really good Parry run earlier
why is that not hitting
there we go
hi sweet girl
[Music]
I'm very confident in that one
not so much that one when I'm not close
how did that not bro God dang it
it's gonna be one of those days sure
oh I know
I'm getting my pets he's right at my
toes
I have a 690 XT AMD graphics card
it's a very nice graphics card
foreign
[Music]
I don't I don't think I'm capable of
carrying that overhead
it it's just
the reason I'm having trouble with the
overhead over and over again is because
if she does any other side step
I've already parried I'm stuck in the
animation and I get hit
but I have to be that fast otherwise I
can't get the Perry
and then if I get hit by the first one
in that I'm staggered can't move get hit
by all the other ones
Melanie is a [ __ ] yeah
have you ever thought about
collaboration with other lore channels I
don't know what we would do
but
no I haven't thought of it
now I can't get that one
I think I have to be like space just a
little bit further away to avoid the
overhand completely
I think if I just try to avoid it
then maybe that would be okay
that was my fault
I missed the window
let's avoid
I'm a little late on that one to the
right
that was my fault
thank you
the gray here
I beat Melania like many many times
these challenge runs make it
very hard obviously
I was still a little bit too close there
I was a little bit too close I need to
back up a little bit I have more room on
the Perry than I think I do
foreign
right
okay I'm gonna let joy out real quick
I'm gonna actually feed joy and then let
her out
foreign
keep going keep going
Joy lays down while she eats by the way
Joy also eats very slowly which I kind
of like about her
well she's eating so
he's doing that
I think that was early
foreign
that which I think would have been a
major mistake
[Music]
I keep wimping out man
that one was late
that just kind of sucks
why do why do I do that
also very bad at that
there we go
nope I was I was too [ __ ] close
I was just too close
uh it would be radagon and eldenbeast
would be the next one we go to
they're the last remaining
right
yeah
has to be
your dog grabs three pieces of kibble at
a time and walks into the living room to
eat it takes them forever why does he do
that
I'm still too [ __ ] close man
wish I knew
interesting
[Music]
because I'm cool with that attack
I'm cool with that one
it's the quick overhead that I don't
like
it's too close that's why she did it
that's like instant death if I get hit
by it bro
even with 99 vigor
yeah the chat's energy has gone into man
why are we fighting this [ __ ]
I think my game crashed
to even the games like why are you
fighting her stupid
oh we didn't fight place to do sex
either that's right [ __ ]
true
yep she literally broke the game it's
like dude this fight sucks why are you
even doing it
[Laughter]
that's gotta be a sign right I'm not
gonna lie I'm having fun uh I'm I'm
literally having fun parrying her
however
I think it's it it's more fun to Parry
her than uh anything else
fighting her legitimately is just stupid
um probably not girl painting Joy you
just ate really fast
now she's gonna slobber and then stick
her nose all over the window and I'm
gonna have to clean it
goes to tushima is a great game
a fantastic game
the legacy of let me Parry her begins
oh by the way I've been work I already
said this earlier but I I'm making new a
new overlay for the Stream
I should have it done by tomorrow
so I hope you guys like it
I hope you guys like it it'll like just
a different designs and stuff than just
having text above and below my head and
whatever
I like designing new stuff sometimes
foreign
I think all that spacing right there was
perfect
I I bailed I bailed
I'm a whim
man if that attack comes in fast it's
pretty much unparable
come on
nice
I wonder why Ukraine it's crazy
yeah dude she she has two variations of
that initial attack she'll either dive
in really fast like that or she'll be
like loaded up and then jump in the load
up is obviously a lot easier to Parry
than anything else
but man
where'd you go where are you
I think she just went to bed how
Joy where'd you go
come here
I don't know where she went
[Music]
my favorite challenge I've done so far
is the um randomizer run which I I
wouldn't even call that big of a
challenge I guess it is but that's that
was my favorite one we've done that was
a lot of fun
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
would you do a run with a gun game mod
where each kill randomizes your weapon
that sounds cool yeah
yeah I know you glory
the fact that she can heal is just
insane
right she can kill me with a single
combo when I have Max health
I don't know I I'm I'm definitely at the
the part with her where she is a total
incomplete
meme
she is meant to be completely unfair
she's meant to be completely unbalanced
she is a meme and
that somehow just makes her night like
better in my brain
you know
just just because of that
thank you
no [ __ ] I'm on your level for her bro
obviously I still think she's a meme
foreign
how did that [ __ ] reach me
wow
and I'm dead
dude
oh my goodness
guys why do you care how long I've been
fighting her I fought Melania for six
hours on 188 attempts Non-Stop
an hour is nothing
Don are you new or something
just don't get how that missed
foreign
right
thank you
holy [ __ ] chat
and she came in fast that time so I
can't Parry her
so weird dude
this has too many variation speeds of
the same [ __ ] attacks
it's part of her great ruin Oliver
it's what her great room does
uh it's a part of the Eldon ring
which gives life
kind of like her flower
foreign
why do you like them Oliver
I I I
just do not understand
that overhead attack it is unreal how
[ __ ] quick it comes in and how you
are staggered into a complete combo
until you are dead
particular
it's not gonna matter zap it doesn't
really do that much
fun boss
I'm having fun pairing her otherwise I
think she's awful
I will die on my I will go to my grave
saying that Melania is a is a bad boss
fight
mechanically
foreign
why not
hearsay to say that I guess
foreign
foreign
all right man
I'm at like uh
yeah
it's fun to Parry her
it really is that's why I keep doing it
over and over again bro
uh
yeah
she's just not fun man
I don't even think people like watching
The Grind for to beat her either anymore
if people liked watching me just like
try and get better at this I'd probably
do it but I just don't think they do
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
are you going to make an edited version
of your Eldon ring drunk stream
challenge you think I should
I was thinking about that
people want to tell how to beat her
I mean if we did that we'd have like
probably 15 000 viewers right now
maybe I'll edit that one instead of this
challenge I don't think this challenge
edited down would be that fun to watch
to be honest with you
it's been a fun stream challenge though
foreign
I did not know she was the blade of
Niccolo
is that right
[Music]
I'll tell you how to beat her no I know
what you meant that and that's what I
meant too
that's that's what I meant too she like
uh people just care about telling you
how to beat her which would be like well
level up all these things
and you know make sure your level at
least 150
and use Frost pots and blah blah blah
blah blah blah all these other things
foreign
I just can't [ __ ] get that man yeah
Circle under a waterfowl
it's just so annoying
I might never come back to the Haley
tree again
I'm not kidding
for every single challenge run we do
from this point on I don't think I want
to come here anymore
I think I'm I think I'm over it
I wonder how the community would feel
about that
foreign
I think I've done my time right
you guys notice there's like permanent
blood in the water right here
maybe that's not permanent
no that's me making that one
but I like fighting Right Guard
personally
you think they'd agree with me
yeah we'd have some of the people like
tryhards say like well invalid run you
didn't fight Melania blah blah blah
obviously
[Music]
[ __ ] man
[Music]
foreign
I think I was still in the stab
animation and couldn't Parry
unfortunately there
foreign
[Music]
that's where I'm at guys
that's where I'm at bro
that's where I'm at with her I'm just uh
I'm at a no on Millennia I just don't
like her
I don't want to fight her man I feel
like now I can't do challenge runs uh
I'm gonna let joy out real quick and
we'll be right back and we'll we'll kill
the we'll kill radagon and the
eldenbeast and we still have to fight
plaster deuce
hold up
foreign
thank you
oh wait
I don't know what do you all think
what do y'all think bro
[Music]
classy
you get cheeser for the hell of it
Cardiac Arrest run or your trash
please stop fighting the sewer [ __ ] no
I mean that's kind of like
that's kind of where I'm at Trey like I
here's the thing I would like to be able
to do
I'm gonna keep doing it while I talk
I would like to be able to do
challenge runs and put them up on
YouTube
okay I would like to do that
but I feel like people are going to hate
those videos if I don't beat this woman
and I don't want that that's that's
literally the only thing I'm thinking of
a few five dollars so at least five more
attempts okay Trump you got it buddy
thank you man
appreciate that a lot
even if they hate it you still make
money off the views that's not what I
care about man
I really don't
I want people to enjoy the videos that I
make
that's all I care about
that is the only thing on my mind
okay Kraken you know what I meant
can't get the right one
foreign
money for attempts
Maybe
maybe it's like you gotta pay me to
fight Melania type of thing
can I even do that
come on
because I do hate her I really do
this boss is like the bane of my
existence in this entire game man it
really is
hold on girl
thank you
oh [ __ ]
I like forgot she can even do that
as a YouTuber myself for over 12 years I
can tell I can tell you stop assuming
what people want to see and just what
makes you happy that's that's what I
want to do I do
I do
but I'm at least doing four more
attempts for pump
foreign
for real
no I have I have not gotten to phase two
yet man I'm still learning the parries
and I'm getting a lot better at the
Paris tit tight what
foreign
foreign
I [ __ ] up and I'm dead that's no
matter how much health you have chat
that's how it works
man bro I guess I could have like insane
armor if I had endurance but I don't
foreign
s make you happy then go for it and if
it's 500 so be it I mean I wouldn't say
I'm happy but I am having more fun
pairing her than anything else I'm
literally still debating in my head
whether I want to keep going
which sucks
I mean we could make a meme of Melania
in this channel that seems to
you know
seems to work
cat likes memes
how how did that literally Miss
what
nice input read there too
this isn't fun to watch I love a close
Millennia battle but this isn't that she
is almost full health when you die
savior out the heartache I mean Trey do
you even understand what Perry's are
that's what I'm trying to learn if I can
Master the Parry I mean I could
literally do the whole fight without
getting hit
however it's extremely difficult
obviously
the fact they have to Parry her three
times in a row is kind of insane
there you go
foreign
[Music]
they're actually hold on
it's time for the Dragon
I don't know I keep I keep thinking I'm
sorry
it's all a given that we hate Melania
I'm just trying to think of a meme we
could do with her
like
I I'm at a point where I never want to
fight her again but I also want to
master the parries
it's a weird spot to be in
[Music]
how does that get her to literally full
health
after all that
never mind
oh God what up Brent
pots Frosty pots pots Lantern maybe JK
love you horny Brent okay hi horny Brent
thank you Brent
thanks for the four months man I
appreciate you bro
thank you man
it's just so crazy like
the amount of perfection that I have to
do every time I fight her is just
annoying
I think this is the last attempt for
what Trump paid for by the way
last attempt and then I think I have a
definitive decision
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yep
all right
that I don't know Bryce or Brad sorry I
saw rice and said Bryce
um
yeah
pairing's the most fun thing you can do
with Melania that's what I learned
that's what I'm learning here
um
sorry trying to fix this thing there we
go
I am at the point where I think Melania
is ridiculously
poorly designed
okay bro
now that didn't say 10 more attempts
Mr Trump
together
good try to dim not mad just
disappointed plus L plus ratio
thank you for the ten dollars Trump I
appreciate that a lot thank you I don't
know what you're saying but
yeah yeah the pairing's fun
thank you Trump
do you want me to try 10 more times
if that's what you're paying for then I
want you to do that
or um I would do that but man dude
you don't have to
I mean I feel like that's what you want
me to do
well let me let me keep let me do a few
more attempts while I say what I want to
say here
and here here's what I'm thinking okay
like I said earlier
I'm worried that
um
my attempts with Melania will be my with
my challenge runs that I want to do not
doing Melania will be looked at very
poorly
that's quite literally the only thing
that's on my mind
I think the only thing that we can do to
get around that
is to have some type of meme in the
community when it comes to fighting her
what I was gonna say
is
we something has to be done in the
community for me to even fight her
right
I don't know if it's like getting paid I
don't know about that like kind of what
Trump's doing right now
but I find her unenjoyable and I really
don't want to do it unless it's like
incentive to do so
so if we can come up with an idea for
that
then
maybe that can be a part of our
challenge runs and a part of the videos
that we make
there has to be some sort of criteria
exactly tack for us to even fight her
because of how much I dislike her
right
does that make sense
otherwise you will never catch me in the
Haley tree ever again
does that make sense
levels of success for challenge runs
Melania is an s-tier success
there I yeah what what do you think the
criteria should be
for you to fight her someone has to pay
for your therapy sessions okay I don't
go to therapy anymore so we don't do
that
we're all poor bastards here dripped
overestimate my bank account
challenge runs almost never do side
bosses just because she has a great room
does not mean it yeah
it's because she heals Trey she heals
every time she hits you
[Music]
it's the only reason
this donut I don't know how they expect
you to not get hit by her
so I guess we can say
I yeah she is a side boss
should we just never do all remembrances
should we always just do
um the game like base game
and then maybe we could have like I'm
just thinking off the top of my head
like a fund to go fight her
or something
I would Trey if I could have my perfect
build you know
the problem is just we don't have the
damage to kill her fast
that's why I'm relying on Perry's
wow nice
foreign
not really Peter I it's definitely the
only way to do it though
at least with this challenge
I think for runs where you get to choose
your build entirely you should go for it
but once you remove the ability to pick
weapons and stuff like that it just
becomes too much of a slog yeah I agree
like it just takes too much
uh repetition to perfect
her
in accordance to the challenge
that it it just takes too much [ __ ]
time it really does it ruins like the
flow of the streams and the challenge
and everything you know
hey Brent
what do you mean angel
it's like she's her own challenge run by
herself
yep [ __ ] away with strength man uh
obviously obviously yeah yeah
the mic's always down bad bro every time
Mike is always down bad
so I'm just trying to think if we if we
can have it be a part of what we do as a
community then I would be fine to
continue doing challenge runs and just
have that be a part of what we do with
Melania every single time
so that's what I'm trying to figure out
like what do we do
as an incentive to fight her and if we
don't hit that incentive we do not come
near her
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
if she comes in fast from a distance
you can't Parry that attack
what if we use chat for summons let me
solo her stream title
uh no
redhead dummy mommy spanks me live on
stream click to view
well at least we got her to that I mean
it dude this is just so stupid
I mean would you guys say that I'm
almost fighting her perfectly and I'm it
the key word there is almost
but [ __ ] man like
insane
maybe I need to just not be scared about
hitting her
well then she just has randomly insane
Poise and gets hit and she gets Health
back
hmm
how the [ __ ] does that reach me man
God I here
yeah damn bro okay
I think what we do from now on is that
we just do any percent
I just don't think we do
Melania I like fighting Moog though
maybe we do any percent from now on and
we always have a timer
right
then maybe we can do them again
and try and do it faster
potentially
that could be maybe that could be cool
foreign
to make that its own category
oh yeah I'll hear you out Brent for sure
[Music]
foreign
side content
agreed
we could act like Melania doesn't exist
yeah we could have like a thousand hours
in the game and just act like we've
never seen her before
this is waterfowl territory isn't it
yep
she did a full 360 around me there to
get me
this [ __ ] boss is so stupid
how many times I've said that today
any thoughts are never doing the
bloodborne building fire the night
trying to play will help him steeple
is that a bloodborne build that'd be
freaking awesome Austin
dude that sounds like a great idea we do
have bloodborne build an elder ring
I'd love that
I guess that missed
whatever
oh good
I'm alive somehow
she has all her health back
yeah what's a Haley tree that doesn't
exist in my mind
foreign
this attempt's been kind of crazy though
yeah in my head just now I said if that
hits me I'm never fighting her again
there it is
[Laughter]
nice
all right I have an idea chat
I know the meme of the community I know
what we're gonna do from this point
forward
I know exactly what we're gonna do
Yep this dis that defined it for me
right there
I know exactly what we're gonna do
and we're gonna come back tomorrow with
a completely new challenge or a new run
that we're gonna do
any mention
from anyone in the comments of normal
videos
and in the streams in the live streams
as well
any comment of the Helix tree of Melania
or anything I'll make an emote or
something
or everyone in the community just says
who's Melania
what's the Haley tree
don't ban him disco what are you talking
about
and never explain why
even if they go on to explain what it is
nobody answered
or you'd say who
who
every time
how does that sound and only the people
that are here right now know that we do
that
Haley tree that's from God of War right
you're right
exactly
I'm gonna be the 80 percent guy from now
on
and we'll have a timer
for every challenge that we do so that
if we want to redo the challenge of any
percent
um do the redo the same challenge then
we can try and beat that previous time
does that make sense
I I'm going to go ahead and fully
acknowledge that Melania
does not exist in my brain
if you no longer exist she's not a thing
okay
you look handsome thank you I appreciate
that Joy really wants to go poop
I said poop and her head just went
yeah who are you talking about
you did a full 180 from lore fighter
outer binder outer to challenge Runner
I just do what I think is fun man
right now I'm waiting for DLC oh
hold on
again
Joy barked at the door and nobody's
there excellent
um Austin I never said thank you for
your 10 by the way I really like that
idea
I definitely want to do that thank you
man
thank you very much
um yeah what's Melania every time she's
mentioned
we don't know who she is
we don't talk about her
she's not a thing we we don't
not a part of uh what we do okay
not a part of it
I love fighting Moog though maybe
sometimes we'll just go fight Moog and
just keep pretending like she doesn't
exist anyway
I love the bloodborne build idea I might
look that up and see what we can do
um but that's gonna do it for the bigger
challenge chat I think we can go on and
beat radagon in the album beasts and
whatever but I'm not gonna make this
this one into a video someone had an
idea earlier of making the drunk stream
into a video and I might do that I think
that would be actually kind of a fun
cute video to just put out so why not
man
um I'll be on tomorrow but I'm gonna get
joy out to go poop you wanna go poop Joy
Joey
here she is
here she is
because the drunk the drunk stream was
actually really fun
it was actually a lot of fun so I'm
gonna be done for today we'll be back
tomorrow around same time 10 to 11 A.M
CST
mind only okay
anyway
guys have a great rest of your night
um I'm glad we figured this out I think
this will just lead to better streams to
be honest with you like pretty much
every time we get to Melania it's just
like
The Vibes just go down heavy heavy
so
yeah
that's all I got joy wants to go she's
getting she's getting mad at me so
thanks for all the support today
we hit our daily member goal which is
actually insane that we can do that
um thank you to funding Joy's treats
she's very thankful she's right here but
is camera shy
um oh and look out for a new UI tomorrow
like the new uh overlays and stuff I
think will look really good so I've been
working on those for a bit
have a great rest of your day and I'll
see you all soon okay all right